mein name ist frank schneider ich bin
seit 28 jahren journalist und 20 jahren
chefreporter bei bilden für immer schon
polizeireporter war bei vielen
terroranschlägen schweren verbrechen und
auch bei amokläufen
[Musik]
schneider aber ein fall der mich nie
losgelassen hat weil er so sinnlos ist
der fall des herrn killers der zwei
menschen getötet hat
[Musik]
daraus entwickelte sich einer der
spektakulärsten fahndung und in
kriminalfällen überhaupt erlebt hat die
polizei ihn in all den jahren seit
gestern abend einen mutmaßlichen
kindermörder
er ist 19 jahre alt 1 meter 75 groß sehr
schlank und trägt vermutlich kann
kleidung
die geschichte war am anfang der mord an
einem kind das schon schrecklich genug
war aber dann entwickelte sich immer
mehr dass dieser täter im internet
offenbar mit seinen taten angebt aber
neue taten ankündigt man fragt sich auch
wie ist ein junger mensch in der lage so
was zu tun vielleicht lag ich noch
nachbar übermacht da das gleiche da habe
ich jetzt zwei morde hoffen als
[Musik]
die haben alle gesagt für uns war ein
harmloser idiotischer spinner der sich
wichtig tag vielleicht wäre das sogar
der ausbildung dass man sehr leger
beweisen wollte ich bin gefährlich ich
bin nicht der berliner lacht jetzt zeige
ich euch mal was ich alles machen kann
er wirklich keine gefühle hat er keine
reue
ich habe alles eher mehr an gefühlen ich
hätte niemals gedacht dass sowas fähig
wäre
ich bin jetzt hier vor der
justizvollzugsanstalt und ich habe
gleich die möglichkeit marcel hesse in
seiner zelle zu besuchen
[Musik]
aber es ist weiter geht da aber ja doch
neben und so läuft es nicht
[Musik]
so wie ich
frechen
[Musik]
bei bleiben
die 10
und 12
[Musik]